what is going through this what is going
through your head
let's show this clip right here
um what's happening what's going through
your mind I don't think he knows how to
deal with a girl from the Bronx
[Applause]
and I don't think she knows how to deal
with the dude from Brooklyn I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it's
February 9 2023 and yes I live in
Florida but I was born in Brooklyn 1976
long time ago we're live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals subscribe if
you haven't uh today we will be doing a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
but before we get to that
it's happening people
you say what's happening Dave well
people do you know what's happening no
we don't could you tell us okay fine
what's happening is what I have been
asking for pleading for begging for
hinting might happen it actually is
happening the Republicans are starting
to go on offense there is momentum
they've got the house they're saying the
right things and now it's not just talk
they're starting to do the right things
so as you guys may have seen over the
course of the last 24 hours as Clips are
leaking out there have been some
Congressional hearings where they are
grabbing the executives over at Twitter
and they are asking them the direct
questions related to Shadow Banning
related to algorithmic manipulation
related to their relationship with the
CIA or the FBI or other government
agencies it is all happening and we got
a bunch of Clips to show you and the
real question what always comes what it
always comes down to is okay we could do
our little dog and pony show we can pull
these people up there and they can
testify under oath and they can lie they
can manipulate they can obfuscate but
will anything come of it that will be
the real challenge for the Republicans
so I'm going to go hard on this thing
today because this can't just be oh we
bring you guys up we do the show the
clips go viral Jim Jordan's you know
crushes Vijaya over at Twitter or Lauren
bobert demolishes uh Joel Roth another
one of the Twitter guys that can't just
end with that it has to end with
something with more teeth and that
really is the challenge there is another
hearing going on that I think will start
while we're doing this live stream so
obviously we'll get to that uh hopefully
some tomorrow and then into next week
and then I think we're going to have
some of the players on the show so
Lauren bobert just agreed that she'll
come on next week
uh we're going to talk to Jim Jordan
we're working on McCarthy which I think
we're going to do live in DC and I just
think the thing might be shifting a
little bit all we want is a little
competency a little accountability you
guys don't have to be great you just got
to be just be a little bit better and
maybe even potentially good and if you
could do that
that's the path that is the way as they
say uh before we get to any of that let
me talk to you guys about gut cleanse
protocol uh you know what leaky gut is
caused by a toxin that's in all of the
quote healthy foods that scientists have
been telling us to eat with a fraudulent
food pyramid for the longest time and
this toxin according to Dr gundry a
world-renowned cardiologist is affecting
millions of people worldwide warning
signs include weight gain and fatigue
and digestive discomfort and stiff and
achy joints even skin problems these
side effects are often mistaken for
normal signs of aging because leaky gut
develops over a matter of years and
sometimes decades the good news is you
can easily be fixed from your own home
it's very simple you just have to know
which foods are actually healthy and
which contain this hidden toxin after
years of research Dr gundry has decided
to release an informative video to the
public free and uninterrupted showcasing
exactly which foods you need to avoid so
you can find this for yourself at
gutcleansprotocol.com Dave that's
gutcleanseprotocol.com Dave go watch Dr
gundry's video at
gutcleansprotocol.com Dave and now back
to me all right here we go so before we
get into the good stuff you know
you know that if Congress is going to
have a hearing you know something stupid
is going to happen it's baked into the
system and when you say stupid and you
say congress the next thing you should
be thinking are three letters a-o-c
so here is congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez or as Dr dad said call us
here Alexandria occasional cortex here
she is basically defending censorship
and kind of calling for more of it here
we go
I'd like to submit to the record a
Washington Post article now warning
about Hunter Biden laptop disinformation
the guy who leaked it
here's the deal before I even get into
my questions I think that the story here
with the New York with the Washington
Post reporting is that what they're
saying right here when the New York Post
first reported in October 2020 that it
had obtained contents of a laptop
computer allegedly owned by Joe Biden's
son Hunter there was an immediate
roadblock faced by other news outlets
that hope to corroborate reporting as
many did the newspaper wasn't sharing
what it obtained
New York Post had this alleged
information and was trying to publish it
without any corroboration without any
backup information they were trying to
publish it to Twitter Twitter did not
let them and now they were upset I
believe that political operatives who
sought to inject explosive
disinformation with the Washington Post
couldn't get away with it
and now they're livid and they want the
ability to do it again they want the
ability to inject this again so they've
dragged a social media platform here in
Congress they're weaponizing the use of
this committee so that they can do it
again
a whole hearing about a 24-hour hiccup
in a right-wing political operation that
is why we are here right now and it is
it's just an abuse of public resources
and abusive public time we can be
talking about health care we could be
talking about bringing down the cost of
prescription drugs we could be talking
about abortion rights Civil Rights
Voting Rights but instead we're talking
about Hunter Biden's half fake laptop
Story I mean this is an embarrassment no
AOC you are an embarrassment and I don't
care how many times you swing your hand
and shake your head and any of that
stuff you are going out of your way to
make sure that the very people in
government and in Tech who are silencing
citizens and politicians alike we'll get
to that in a moment you are going out of
your way to make sure they can do it
again because the only way you and your
stupid regressive ideas gain any
traction is if you can censor people
there is so much Ridiculousness in what
she just said there first off she keeps
calling it an alleged laptop an alleged
story it's not alleged it is confirmed
even the freaking leftist lunacy of the
New York Times even they have confirmed
it nobody is doubting anymore whether
the laptop the hunter Biden laptop which
he dropped off to the repair shop is
real whether the images of him naked
smoking crack with the hookers all the
nobody is debating whether it is
real or or not it is real and it is
relevant to things going on in our
government because he was also renting
for fifty thousand dollars a month his
dad's house his dad happens to be
president of the United States and it
turns out that in the garage next to the
Corvette are a bunch of classified
documents so these things could not be
more relevant but she can't have you
actually keeping your eye on the ball
she has to make it seem like this is
some sort of crazy right-wing conspiracy
she also says uh well then okay so she
says it's alleged she also says it's a
half fake laptop meaningless dribble me
it is a real legit period you know it uh
and then she says that their Weapon It's
the Republicans who are weaponizing this
committee
and like almost everything she says that
is a complete flip on what the truth is
the Republicans are using this committee
to try to figure out how the government
was involved with Twitter and how
Twitter itself was using a certain set
of policies publicly but then privately
doing completely other things meaning
Shadow Banning depressing uh views
making sure that certain people were
promoted and certain people were hidden
and everything else and how that might
be related to an election and you would
think that these clowns like AOC and the
and the uh era the shifts the atom ships
and the Pelosi's you would think all of
these people who screamed about big Tech
manipulation and Russian Bots had
somehow created a situation that got
Donald Trump elected well that's
completely falling apart but you would
think that they felt that Twitter was so
important Twitter was such an integral
part of the election process that maybe
it is important that we now know that
there was government collusion and that
activist employees we're silencing
people but she doesn't want you to know
that and she she is a liar and a fraud
and an embarrassment as a public servant
just an absolute embarrassment there's
no other way to put it but let's just do
a deep dive on all of this because this
didn't just magically appear yesterday
right this this the questions about all
of this stuff have been going on for at
least I'd say in in the public sphere
about five or six years you can go back
we'll over the next couple weeks we'll
show you a whole bunch of interviews I
was doing five six years ago there's one
particular one I did with Eric Weinstein
where we basically and mostly Eric but
I'm asking the question so I guess I was
kind of leading him in a certain way uh
he basically just completely uh
uncovered exactly what Twitter was doing
it wasn't that hard to find like we were
asking all the right questions and it
was obvious that they were they were
Shadow bands they were obvious backdoors
ways the government was getting involved
and a whole bunch more but when it
really bursts forth into the public was
in 2 2019 you might remember this Vijaya
got a who is the other yoel Roth was one
of the main guys uh testifying yesterday
he was the trust and safety guy Vijaya
got a was the lead counsel lawyer over
at Twitter you may remember when she
went on Joe Rogan's podcast
2019 and Tim Poole was there Tim Tim is
an actual journalist he's become a
superstar in this space and Rogan kind
of just sat back and lit and let Tim
Poole do the work but here they are
Vijaya Rogan and Tim and here is Vijaya
basically lying about content moderation
Shadow Banning Etc
at what point would you guys restrict
someone from sharing info like false
information about vaccines that could
get someone hurt
that is not a violation of Twitter's
rules no but I want I wanted to just
kind of uh get into that statement you
made about misinformation and whether or
not you'll police it so I think that the
tough part of this is really and love to
have a discussion about this is do you
really want corporations to police
what's true and not true absolutely not
that's a really really tough position
but you guys do that we try not to do
that we don't want
man pool hope you're watching dude
credit where credit is due but you guys
do it and her answer we try not to which
if you just have half a brain you would
think well we try not to So that
obviously means that we do and if it
means that you do then that means there
are mechanisms baked into the system at
Twitter and you can extrapolate that
into Facebook and to YouTube and
everywhere every one of the freaking
apps on this thing that they have ways
of silencing people they have either
kill switches or they can just shut off
certain accounts Shadow ban depress the
algorithm whatever magical phrase
whatever newfangled phrase they want to
use to come up with that so at that
moment at that moment we try not to
everyone should have known that's what
they do and when they say we try not to
now I actually believe to some extent
that they probably a certain amount of
them probably didn't want to go ahead
and censor everybody there's going to be
some evidence of that we're going to
show you in just a moment but
they all have their political biases and
as Elon Musk is now well aware having
fired half the company and still having
a whole bunch of leftist activists there
the stuff the leftist ideology the woke
nonsense started getting baked into the
code so people did not even know when
they were being banned there were the
this is why they brought me to Twitter a
couple weeks ago there were the obvious
labels on certain people's accounts one
of them was my friend Charlie Kirk his
account had been labeled with you know
right wing or something to that effect a
label that was could be seen by any of
the programmers there what they found on
my account was it was way deeper there
was nothing obvious on my account to
show why it was Shadow banned it was way
deeper in the code and the more they dig
the more they find I actually spoke to
one of the engineers yesterday he said
they're still finding more stuff on my
account and I'm not making this about me
it was they used my account as the
example because I was ranting and raving
about it but now they're finding this
about all sorts of people including
Lauren bobert congresswoman Lauren
bobert from Colorado and if you want to
see when I talk about Republicans are
getting balls they are starting to fight
back they are not taking prisoners and
again we'll have to see what they
actually do about it not just talk but
watch this this is just great so this is
Lauren bobert talking to Joel Roth who
is the head of trust and safety at
Twitter regarding her own personal
personal and also public government
Twitter account Mr Roth while at Twitter
how many meetings did you have with the
FBI
I couldn't say for sure but more than
10. that's the reason
I couldn't say for sure more than 50.
that seems a bit High
many meetings with the FBI well we know
uh how many FBI agents worked at Twitter
while you were there I don't believe any
active FBI former FBI agents how many
worked there while you were there
I'm aware of perhaps two well we know of
at least nine because they started the
bu group chat bu for Bureau
okay so we got more of that but I wanted
to stop there because there's a couple
things going on here first off there are
former FBI employees and there were many
of them she knows of at least nine there
are probably more that were working at
Twitter I think some of them may still
be at Twitter at the moment so now the
question that that isn't inherently you
can work at the FBI and then work at a
private company and then bounce around
you can do all those things so that
isn't inherently evil unless part of
what they were doing there and it does
kind of sound like it was working for
the FBI right doing the the work of the
FBI while no longer technically working
at the FBI that's an issue I do want to
offer the slightest defense of Joel Roth
here because he if the FBI is calling
you right if the FBI started calling me
and being like Dave we want to talk
about what you're doing on the show well
I'm the boss I'm the boss of this thing
so if that then changed policies of what
I do here what I talk about or what I
don't talk about it would all fall on me
yoel Roth he was the head of trust and
safety but he was not the CEO of the
company so so to just pile it all on him
might be a little bit much because Jack
Dorsey was the CEO for all of this Jack
Dorsey who had been hauled in front of
Congress and and basically lied to Ted
Cruz and I once tweeted at him do you
Shadow band simply yes or no will work
and we have the Tweet he says no one
word that's it I actually texted Lauren
right before the show I thought maybe
she would uh she's working on it we're
trying to find out if they actually
tried to get Jack Dorsey who's no longer
at Twitter those guys aren't there
either anymore but if they tried to get
him involved in this hearing as well
anyway it's not to excuse
Roth from talking to the FBI but I think
the next step in this thing Republicans
you want to you want to start doing the
right thing you got to haul some FBI
representatives in front of Congress and
have them testify under oath what were
you pressuring the Twitter people to do
because the point is if the FBI shows up
at anyone's office
and puts pressure on someone that's just
an employee of a company to do something
they might do it because they don't want
to get in jail they don't want to be
want to be blackmailed God only knows
what these freaking people are doing so
you can't just blame that on him you
have to find out what was the FBI doing
that's that's the next step in this uh
but here is bobert going off on Roth
Vijaya Gotti and this guy Jim Baker who
is the council who actually was I
believe part of the FBI if I'm not
mistaken over their violations of her
first amendment speech Mr Baker said
that there was no collusion with the
federal government and Twitter but Mr
Baker that's you you are the collusion
between the federal government and the
FBI and now with it this is such a
problem because
we're seeing censorship all over Mr Roth
Miss Gaddy did either of you approve the
shadow Banning of my account at Lauren
bobert
yes or no no I did not
to the best of my recollection well let
me refresh your memory because on March
12 2021 and Mr Roth I know you looked at
it because fascia's Twitter 1.0 had a
public interest exceptions policy which
means for members of Congress to be
Shadow banned it had to go before you Mr
Roth so I'll ask again did you Shadow
ban my account yes or no
again not to the best of my recollection
so the answer is Mr oth yes you did I
found out last night from Twitter staff
that you suppressed my account for this
tweet it's a freaking joke about Hillary
Clinton being angry that she couldn't
rig her election it's a joke but in
response being the Sinister overlords
that you all are you placed a 90-day
account filter so I could not be found
and now we see here that Twitter staff
said the visibility filter on my account
excluded me from top searches prevented
notifications for non-followers and much
more this is considered an aggressive
visibility filter you silenced members
of Congress from communicating with
their constituents you could you
silenced me from communicating with the
American people over a freaking joke now
who the hell do you think that you are
man
what do they call that what do they call
that kind of woman that's like Fed Up
soccer mom or something whatever that is
but that is the attitude Republicans
need more so again you can either put
all the blame on Joel Roth or on Vijaya
Gotti or this guy Jim Baker Jim Baker by
the way I mean he's the the most
interesting piece of this thing even
though people talk about him the least
this guy was the general counsel at the
FBI
he was a lawyer like a big time Big Shot
high-powered lawyer at the FBI and then
you know what his job was at Twitter
general counsel at Twitter huh you think
you think something's going on here so
again I don't think you can put all the
blame on these people completely because
there was pressure from the government
that's why this is a First Amendment
issue if Lauren bobert was just
screaming at them you guys as a private
company did this well there's something
to be exposed there right because for
years we've been all screaming about
Russia collusion on all these Russia
Bots that somehow manipulated the
election which of course all turned out
to be a lie so she would be well within
her right to be going after Twitter for
whatever they're doing whatever their
information they're manipulating that
doesn't make it a First Amendment issue
it becomes a First Amendment issue when
government agents are pressuring these
people to do things and when you find
out that there are at least nine former
FBI officials working at the company
that the general counsel of Twitter is
the former general counsel of the FBI I
mean it does not take a rocket science
scientist I don't know how many little
things I got to draw together to give
you some kind of picture that's going to
make a little bit of sense here bobert
continued election interference yeah I
would say that that was taking place
because of you for sitting here the
hunter Biden laptop story was suppressed
a sitting member of Congress was
suppressed a sitting president was
banned from Twitter you know I bet that
Putin is sitting in the Kremlin wishing
he had as much election intervention
interference as you for here today we've
heard about threats to democracy well
what about shutting down a duly elected
member of Congress this is fundamental
to our nation's governance and you all
attacked that very Foundation
yeah that's right that's right and look
there is that risk of the scapegoat
thing and I want to be very careful
about that but if
they did this in coordination with the
government then we have an epic Scandal
and it seems like we do have that uh did
they on their own decide that the hunter
Biden laptop thing had to come down that
the story had to come down and you
wouldn't be able to share it or anything
else or did say it have something to do
with the 51 former intelligence
officials who all said it was Russian
disinformation right remember that New
York Post had a great cover where they
showed all of their faces and they all
completely lied about it it was true so
that's why this is so important because
what we are seeing here it's not just
that that bad actors at companies can do
things and we don't know what they're
doing and by the way that's still
happening at Twitter right now they know
that that's still going on there they
were bad actors and there's also even if
you fire all the Bad actors you still
got stuff in the code right you still
got in the mire and the muck there's
still bad code written in there as
Lauren's talking about they just found
out deep within her account was the
stuff that was deep within my account so
in it exists so that's why elon's job is
so complex it's why he described this
thing as a Jenga that you know you pull
out one piece and you think you've got a
stable product and then next thing you
know the thing collapses on you or
that's tiramisu cake metaphor that he
used so there is a lot to do here uh it
continued here's uh representative Jim
Jordan and he has been waiting for this
for a long time he is I've had him on
the show a couple of times he has been
waiting for the moment he would be able
to to grill some execs on the hunter
Biden situation
that it was fake didn't tell you that it
was hacked uh and and Mr Roth did the
did the story violate your policies
in my judgment at the time no it did not
yeah that's what you said said what I
would propose excuse me is you said it
isn't clearly a violation of our hack
materials policy nor is it clearly a
violation of anything else
so I think what a lot of people are
wondering is if it didn't violate your
policies
and they didn't tell you it was fake
didn't tell you it was hacked why'd you
take it down
the company made a decision that found
that it did violate the policy it wasn't
my personal Judgment at the time that it
did but the decision was communicated to
me by my direct supervisor and
ultimately I didn't disagree with it
enough to object you know you know what
you know what I think happened Mr Roth I
think I think you guys got played
I think you guys wanted to wanted to
take it deep down we saw what but the
chairman put up where you said you know
everyone in the white house isn't as a
fascist I think you guys wanted to be
taken down
I think you meet with these guys every
week we know that's been established in
the Twitter files you had weekly
meetings with Mr Chan and the run-up to
the election they send you all kinds of
emails they send you documents on the
super secret James Bond teleporter you
get information on that
I think you guys wanted to take it down
I think you guys got played by the FBI
so Jim Jordan's doing something pretty
clever here that gets to the heart of
this so the the question did you guys
violate policy well Joel Roth is saying
uh we didn't we didn't violate policy
until until the higher-ups forced me to
do it that's why I don't want to purely
scapegoat this one random guy right I'm
not defending him in any way but who who
is his direct supervisor now if he was
the head of trust and safety I'm
guessing his supervisor might be Jack
the CEO or whoever that is that's the
guy they have to haul in next to figure
this out right because again if it was
the boss man the head supervisor who got
the call from the government then
there's your Smoking Gun so they're
getting close like they actually are
getting close to something again will
anything come up this I have no freaking
idea but we're starting we're starting
to get that puzzle I'm always talking
about man it's starting to the pieces
are coming together and we're starting
to see what actually we've been putting
together here the entire time I also
think Jim Jordan's right that you got
played meaning what he means by that is
you got guys had your own biases you
would have loved to taken the hunter
Biden laptop thing down because you
wanted Joe to get elected you would have
done anything that you wanted to uh to
do to get Trump out of the White House
Etc you got played meaning once there
was enough
smoke and even though the smoke was not
real but once it was sort of there and
you felt some pressure then you didn't
even have to abide by your own policies
again this this he was the head of trust
and safety he's the one in the email
that Jim Jordan right there is quoting
basically saying it doesn't violate our
policies but there was enough there that
you know they can just kind of push you
in the right way okay interesting Jim
Jordan then last night went on Tim
Poole's podcast which they shot from
Lauren bobert's office a lot of names
here uh and they mentioned a little
something about me and Elon and what
else has been going on over there there
are these apps you can use where you
enter your name and it'll tell you the
various filters that exist but even Dave
Rubin just mentioned Elon Musk just
showed him new ones they discovered new
filters so one of the questions asked
too that he made me think of this too I
asked this question
um and I I didn't fully understand but
but I asked if they were hard coding
into any specific accounts to censor
them so they're like targeting that
specific user and it was interesting how
Joel Roth kind of I want to go back and
look at the transcript to see exactly
how he said it because he really didn't
answer that square
um that either I agree one of the things
we want to do with with legislation that
we're we're planning on work doing with
Energy and Commerce Committee
is anything they do to your account they
have to tell you there has to be real
transparency there has to be a time
frame there has to be a due process so
that you can correct it figure out what
it is to have the debate and correct
within a specified amount of time and
then if they don't then you should have
some kind of cause of action because
they're violating a contract that they
have with you their user their customer
okay so I like the end of that right
he's talking about the the user
agreement we all sign that means you
have responsibilities they have
responsibilities you know sort of like
when you buy a product and that product
blows up in your face they might be held
accountable for that I do and we will
reach out to Jim Jordan's team
immediately after the show we put this
thing together on the Fly today when
he's talking about is it hardwired to
people's specific accounts I know that
the answer is yes because when we did
the Deep dive into my account they found
things that were just on my account and
then they they've also found that they
were on other people's accounts as well
but meaning they were going it was
account specific we don't like Dave
Rubin we're going to attach this stuff
from related to misinformation and be
like it was literally like being mean
and like a couple other things so we
know that it is hardwired in there and
that's why it's so difficult to uh to
take out and uh I will we'll get that to
Jim George Jim are you watching this is
for you dude anyway if you want to see
how ridiculous this is and how the lies
get laundered so we started with AOC
basically mocking the entire hearing not
being upset that People's First
Amendment rights were infringed on again
because if the government which it
sounds like it was these FBI agents were
pressuring people's speech to be taken
off Twitter that is a violation of your
response she doesn't care about that she
she confuses the issue related to the to
the laptop as if it is not real we know
it is real and it's all you know
right-wing conspiracy and everything
else well how does that sort of lie then
get laundered through the system well
the way it does is that when you turn on
CNN tonight and God bless you I know
you're not going to do it but if you
have an NPC cousin who watches NBC CNN
or NBC Nightly News or whatever it might
be tonight they're not going to see
anything about these hearings what they
are going if they if they get anything
it'll be a little bit of the aoca oh so
you didn't believe that the hearings
were worth hearing at all
on MSNBC here is Joe Scarborough and Jen
saki you like how jensaki has somehow
made a return to this show how did this
happen I thought we buried her bones
like Freddy Krueger you know if you bury
the bones they don't come back
but anyway she's still here uh and
here's their analysis of what happened
analysis please
these things never
produce the punch they expect
and to go back to Mike markle's earlier
point I mean this is like a word salad
of right wing craziness right I mean and
if you are just a normal person 80 of
the country by the way that is not on
Twitter and you're hearing things like
Durham woke mobs many of the sentences
in Sarah Huckabee Sanders's speech the
other night you you'll tune in and you
think I have no idea what you're talking
about I I am I have to go buy eggs My
Health Care is too expensive my
prescription drugs are too expensive I'm
not sure about gas it seems down but I
don't want it to go up and it just feels
very far away so in a strange way the
this Republican strategy right now has
made them seem like this like right wing
Elite society that is not connected with
what is actually happening in the
country and she is just awful I'm gonna
have to rearrange my list of awful
people she just moved up a couple
notches because Corrine jump here we do
so much on her she had kind of jumped
her but if she's back if Saki back baby
I'm moving her up the thing like she's
she's no one's beating Joy Reed but she
might be in Sunny Hosten level at this
point we're gonna have to get the whole
chart out uh the thing is I have so many
women of The View on that thing maybe
it's not fair you get you got your
Ayanna in here anyway
um
it's interesting because Jan sake is
seemingly upset that people are not
happy with prices of eggs and gas prices
and the price of Health Care uh who
remind me guys who's the president of
the United States what's his name again
Joseph R Biden and who worked for him a
few gen Saki these people are such epic
clowns and also that Joe Scarborough is
saying these things never pack the punch
they want how much more of a punch do
you want than a member of Congress
saying I have evidence that you this
giant tech company were censoring me
before an election and I have evidence
from the company itself and we know that
government agents were working with the
company to do it there was collusion
with the FBI how is that not packing a
punch what he means by that is I'm going
to ignore the important things so I can
put on this hack sake to babble about
some irrelevant
this is Watergate level stuff honestly
it really is it really is uh but if you
want to see what sake does I know it's
an oldie but a goodie here's sake in
July of 21 admitting that this is
exactly what they do which is why she
wants to you to focus on the prices of
eggs right now which again are the fault
of her former boss this is a big issue
of misinformation specifically on the
pandemic in terms of actions Alex that
we have taken or we're working to take I
should say from the federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for Facebook that
spread this information we're working
with doctors and medical professionals
to connect to Connected medical experts
with popular with popular who are
popular with their audiences with uh
with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping get
trusted content out there you get it
guys like she did it they flagged posts
for Facebook for Twitter Godly knows
what's going on on YouTube etc etc so
that's why they don't want you to cover
this story because that that paid Bounty
Hunter liar for the White House sake now
pretends to be a news Analyst at MSNBC
how freaking ridiculous and they do it
all right in front of our faces that's
why my challenge to Republicans my
challenge to Jim Jordan and Lauren
bobert and Kevin McCarthy and all of you
people is this is the time you cannot
let them get away with it they cannot
get away with it now find out Hall sake
in front of Congress and make her
explain what that whole thing about
flagging meant and how Facebook we know
this now Facebook had this back end way
that government officials could contact
Facebook employees and vice versa so
this stuff is happening they've admitted
it but the the machine will launder the
lies because it's a giant shell game
every time you think you know that the
ball is under that shell they Shuffle it
real quick and they get you just they
get you distracted on some other issue
we're going to stay focused on that one
holy shmoly let's get to some
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
questions and I guess there'll be
something about something like this we
shall think Amy says uh with Disney's
streaming subscription cancellations
movies flopping in the theaters and
stock prices in Decline do you have any
hope that they will abandon their woke
indoctrination in the near future and if
so should we forgive them and start
opening our wallets for them once again
or shut the door on them permanently
what was the number I saw a tweet on
this this morning I think Disney has
lost
2.4 million Disney plus subscribers they
just announced they're gonna have
massive massive layoffs because people
have had it with the woke nonsense by
the way we didn't get to cover it this
week but you know the DeSantis fight
with Disney uh he got rid of their
airport he got rid of their tax breaks
there's a whole bunch more there's going
to be a board a government appointed
board that will deal specifically with
Disney issues they are not going to have
a carte blanche to do whatever the hell
they want anymore which is absolutely
fantastic yeah 2.4 million people cancel
Disney plus so Disney plus if I don't
know how much Disney plus was let's say
it was 6.99 a month something roughly
like that 2.4 million people a month go
a year on that thing it's a lot of cash
and now they're they're
firing people to your point though about
so what do we do after like if they
start turning this stuff around I'm not
that interested in giving these guys my
money I'm not I look I still have Hulu
Hulu put out the 1619 project I got the
Golden Girls on there I just need the
Golden Girls DVDs guys my birthday's in
June and I need a DVD player now too
it's a lot
but everyone should be using their
dollar their purchase power in a way
that's congruent with their beliefs and
their life like you don't want to fund
it's one thing for these things to be
out there uh actively working against
you and your beliefs it's another thing
to be funding them while they do it uh
it's about 200 million dollars a month
sorry 20 million dollars a month that
Disney lost on these subscriptions about
140 a year 140 million look that does
that for a company like Disney that is
not an unbelievable amount but they've
also had several failures you know Star
Wars land absolutely sucked
um they they have this other like a lot
of their stuff is not quite working and
parents have just had it you can find
other things to do with your kids so I I
don't think look if they genuinely
turned around and it's not to say they
can't make anything good like I actually
can't think of any is there anything
what's the last Disney thing that you
think was good like I don't know like
who who knows Lion King what year was
that around 1990 Lion King was pretty
good like The Lion King you're a yeah
you like that uh Little Mermaid don't
you I feel like you're a little mermaid
guy
Robin Hood you're a robin a guy anyway
the point is don't fund your own demise
Elizabeth says have you found the things
that you uh have you found the things
that you love most about David and vice
versa have changed since the boys were
born I found that to be true with my
husband after Izzy's arrival well you
know it's like it's like so much changes
like my life has just changed in a way
that I can't fully describe like it's
not there's the obvious reasons like
that the sleep is Disturbed and when I
in between the show from you know we
wrap up the show here usually your lunch
arrives in 20 minutes I get I get a
quick 20 minutes with the kids I start
my day with them maybe there's a diaper
change or I walk we took a nice long
walk today with the with the double
stroller and now Luke's growing so fast
that they they really are looking like
twins at this point
um but is there anything specific about
David he's just done an unbelievable job
like I get it we don't have a woman here
right we're two dudes that's different
that that's a little weird I actually
accept that that's that's out of the
Norm it absolutely is it doesn't mean
it's it doesn't mean it's worse it
doesn't mean it's better it's whatever
we make it to be and we do have a lot of
female influences around we've had both
grandmothers around and David's sister
has been around and my sister has three
kids and she lives in Miami
um and we're doing the best we can on
all those things but he has just done a
freaking unbelievable job on all
accounts these we had the the
pediatrician
because we have two of them it's a pain
in the butt to be taking them to
different pediatrician appoints
appointments so we have a pediatrician
that comes to the house and she was so
it she came yesterday the day before she
was so impressed with these kids the
growth their their dispositions the
amount that they're eating every they're
they're they're like off the charts on
everything and uh so far so good but I
guess we will revisit this in about 18
years uh Daisy says discounting all
sports what is your dream job
I mean honestly I'm doing it I'm doing
what I'm supposed to be doing this is
what I'm supposed to be doing and and I
wake up every day and I have purpose and
I love doing it and I feel like I'm
being rewarded accordingly for it kind
of like spiritually nourishing but also
financially and building good things I'm
I'm doing I've told you guys many times
before in my high school yearbook
everyone said I was going to host the
Tonight Show it's like well I didn't do
that but this is pretty close pretty
close close enough uh Fred says I
believe the bifurcation of the country
is founded in a basic disparity in the
perceived value of being American how
can we increase pride and value of being
an American in individuals using actions
and programs not debate even something
as simple as advertising our positive
activities could have a meaningful
impact on citizen sentiment this is a
great point because look the political
layer of this maybe cannot get solved
how how do I solve for an AOC right
someone who
personally professionally her belief set
her behavior her ideas they're so
profoundly different than mine now she
happens to be a congresswoman in in New
York she should have virtually nothing
to do with my life here in Florida but
Congress people they do have some
national you're well you're seeing it
today these Congressional hearings there
they have some power over us even if you
live 3000 miles away from them right you
live in Cali Florida 3 000 miles but
somehow Eric swalwell does have some
influence let's say on the intelligence
committee which is no longer on over
your life because you do live in America
I don't know how we put those things
together but I would say to your point
the best thing you can do is just be a
little better than that it sounds cliche
but it's so true first off it's not hard
they're hysterical and angry and they
don't know what they're talking about
and one of the things that I think
helped me along uh this political
journey is that as I talk to more
conservative leaning people or
Libertarians or whatever it might be I
just thought they were nicer and and
more pleasant and honestly looked better
and I don't mean that at a superficial
level I mean it at a oh you take care of
yourself level where the other side
there's a reason that so many of the
walksters look so ridiculous and and
awful and out of shape and all that
stuff and it's because they don't
believe in personal responsibility so I
don't know that we can fix this all at
the political level I think there are
certainly signs for it that was the
point of the whole first half of today's
show but we can fix it at the sort of
individual and then Community level I
think that's it uh Joe says it seems
like the Supreme Court will repeal
affirmative action for college
enrollment specifically in regards to
the students for fair admissions Inc
versus Harvard case while the case is
still ongoing and the ruling has not
been released most pundits feel the
policy will be abolished what are your
thoughts on the topic I am completely
against affirmative action affirmative
action is racism of another name the
basic idea and this is what lefties do
with everything okay black people
suffered some level of Oppression and
that is true slavery did happen and of
course the welfare state came in and
destroyed their families and kept people
in cycles of poverty and everything else
many people got out of that there were
millions and millions of black people
doing really well and they were doing
really really well under Donald Trump
but when you come in and you say a
hiring process at a company or an
admissions process at a university which
is this is that's what that case is
specifically we'll look at the color of
skin the average Lefty is like oh that's
good like okay black people should get a
leg up and we should do something for
them and they don't think about it
beyond that but all you have to do is
think about it for one more second if a
school has a hundred slots and says well
first off they seem to love quotas they
love this idea if we should have X
amount of this and x amount of that and
x amount of this it's like all right
well then you just want the person it's
racist and bananas in and of itself but
once you say we have a hundred thoughts
and 80 of those slots now must go to
black people let's say well you are
punishing the Asian kid who has been
busting his butt for years whose parents
came here with nothing they taught him
about hard work and education and he did
after school activities and didn't get
into trouble and did it all by the books
and you are you are uh discriminating
against that kid and then what do you
think a kid who has been discriminated
against in a society will do with the
rest of his life he might be pretty
resentful of it and it would be well
worth it so the only playing field that
you can have is an even playing field if
if you want to set up Society for
success and that encourages everybody to
work as hard as they possibly can but
once you say this color skin those
genitals whatever it might be are going
to get this person in you will degrade
the product you will not get the best of
the best and and why does that matter
for society well let's say you're going
to Harvard and now Harvard has decided
instead of hiring just
blindfolded here admitting the best
hundred kids well now they've got a
disparity there's some kids which
definitely shouldn't have got there and
they've taken kids who definitely should
have gotten in they don't get in now
these kids are going to grad school
right some of them want to be I don't
know pre-med let's say they're pre-med
undergrad now they wanted to get into
grad school they want to be a doctor
well they got in with lesser grades now
they get to pre-med with lesser grades
oh that's interesting okay now they're
getting out of pre-med and they're going
to get their first they want to they're
going to be an intern at a hospital
whatever it might be and then they're in
competition there and they look at their
skin color and they go oh you better get
in well now they got into undergrad grad
and the job entry at a lower level on
everything and then one day they're
performing heart surgery and you don't
have the best heart surgeon you have the
guy that was given every opportunity it
does not inherently mean he's bad
certainly does not I would not care
whether my heart surgeon or my airline
pilot is black white or anything else
until you idiots make us care you make
us care because you have said we will
not hire the best people to do the most
important work we will actually hire
people based on these immutable
characteristics and then what that
causes is a slow uh destruction of the
functionality of society and nothing
will work properly because all of the
best people will self-select out or
they'll move to Florida James says now
that we're in the 2024 election campaign
season which Republican will step up to
run against Donald Trump there are many
good candidates for a running mate which
one would he pick well we know that uh
for sure that
um Nikki Haley's getting involved looks
like Mike Pompeo is going to get
involved obviously DeSantis is The X
Factor here I think maybe Tim Scott
could get involved it sounds like Larry
Elder is going to get involved like
there's going to be some interest
there's always like a random billionaire
who gets involved like there's going to
be some interesting jockeying there and
I think it'll be it'll be a nice battle
on that side as I keep telling you the
the main issue is what Trump wants to do
here it seems to me he's lost a lot of
momentum a lot of support it's not that
people don't like the message it's not
that people don't like make America
great again it's not that people don't
think he did a way better job than Trump
I think there's a feeling it's partly
aged but it's also that his time has
gone that the machine maybe wouldn't let
him be elected again that we've seen the
most amount of votes he could get how
can he bring in new people who's going
to suddenly be like ah I've come around
on Donald Trump
um and and that would all lead you to
think that someone like DeSantis is the
standard Bearer for that and I would
love to see those guys work together by
the way I think you can make arguments
against DeSantis as well as a Floridian
I can make a very clear one which is
that the freaking Federal machine is
evil and we've got the best guy here why
give our best guy to the federal machine
to be chewed up and spit out that as a
as a Floridian is a is a really strong
argument to stay here the argument
against that is well we're in a freaking
battle for Western society and we better
put our best guys on the chessboard and
this is our best guy so let's see what
what can happen there but would he be as
a effective in in all of the world
affairs that that is he the force of
nature that Trump is probably not quite
is he possibly more competent than Trump
and would staff better than Trump
probably so there's pros and cons to all
of these guys I just don't want the
mutually assured destruction with them
and I have to say that watching Trump
over the last week or so I haven't even
been covering it on the show because I
don't even want to give it air really
he's saying really awful ridiculous
things about DeSantis and it's like dude
if that's the way you're going to go out
that you're going to take our best guy
and just level crazy accusations and
scorched Earth on them like I'm not that
impressed with that either
all that said there is a way I could end
up voting for him and we will see what
happens uh I happen to like Nikki Haley
I was very impressed with Pompeo some of
the foreign policy stuff on Ukraine
wasn't my thing but I thought as a as a
communicator I thought he was quite good
he was friendlier than I anticipated and
we'll see who else gets gets involved
Liberty says I've never heard you really
talk much about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies as someone who leans
libertarian most of the issues I'd
assumed Financial Freedom and
decentralization would be things that
you support I think allowing government
to get so involved in banking was a
terrible idea but was a necessity at the
time is it time for a new Option a
trustless system love to hear your
thoughts yeah we've done a couple little
shows on bitcoin over the years and I've
mentioned things here and there first of
the general idea of decentralization not
having one fed that controls all the
rates and all the money and One Bank in
charge of everything and it doesn't you
don't even have to do this just at a
financial level like a media that is
truly centralized the way our media
seems to be centralized we have seen the
decentralization of media YouTube Rumble
all of these things popping up and now
there are new voices hopefully that are
giving you something a little more true
than than the nonsense that the
centralized systems pump out you always
wonder why how do all these seemingly
good people start barking the same epic
over and over and it's because
it's it's just centralized thought
humans are meant to be decentralized
having systems of individuals that kind
of come together to build things and go
up this way that's why it's always so
hilarious when Biden talks about his
bottom-up and middle-out economy and
it's like no it's the other way for you
dude I know he doesn't know which way is
up so is what it is on the on the crypto
side the idea of of payments
decentralized payments that are end to
end meaning you want to buy something
for me I want to buy something from you
I can send you this digital currency you
can store it you can save it as you see
fit there is no way because it's
decentralized for someone to come in and
freeze your account or take it from you
like what was basically happening in
Canada with freezing of bank accounts
that you could basically have Commerce
have exchange barter with people outside
of the system that is very good we've
got a little bit of Bitcoin I've got
some of the other stuff which most of
it's not doing too hot these days and uh
yeah I would recommend people just learn
more about it but we also need it's not
just decentralization on the financial
side you know a decentralized video is
something that Rumble is working on and
locals has been working on for a long
time but all these things they're
fraught with with difficulties because
once something is decentralized so if
you put a decentralized video out on the
internet meaning it lives on all these
different computers and if one goes down
another one jumps in and helps and keeps
it up so it basically exists Forever on
one hand that sounds nice it's like okay
YouTube couldn't shut me off tomorrow if
we were fully decentralized right now
that's that's spectacular but now what
if it was something horrific what if it
was a snuff film what if it was child
porn do you want that to never be able
to be taken down these are a lot of the
issues that we've been grappling with
when we're when we're trying to figure
out what direction we want to go with
Rumble and locals uh talway says I've
always wondered who are three people
Dave has never had the opportunity to
interview but has always wanted and why
I've answered versions of this question
before I mean George Lucas I still
I I still would love to talk to him
about the creation of Star Wars the
political messaging behind it what it
was like to sell to Disney does he
regret any of that what's it like to to
create something that is the thing of
dreams and then watch your own fan base
go after you but then also have had Give
It Away out of somewhat level of
frustration but become super
unbelievably wealthy in the process but
then see the guys you sold the two run
it into the ground like there's so much
there related to art and human drive on
top of all the cool science fiction
stuff and all that uh so that's one for
sure Elon obviously at this point like I
have never interviewed him I've sat with
him but I've never interviewed him and I
think that would be absolutely
spectacular and I'll give you one a
little bit a little bit out there uh I
don't know how many more years she'll
have on this Earth I would love love
love and she doesn't do much press
anymore and I think she lives in
Switzerland I would love to sit down
with Tina Turner
um there's a documentary on HBO I think
it's called I Tina or it might just be
called tina is she he's just I just love
her story this girl that came from nut
Bush Tennessee with nothing she marries
Ike you know she gets in the band they
have this horrific
insanely abusive relationship if you've
seen the movie What's Love Got to Do
with it I mean they get into it it's a
book I think as well
um but she's perseveres and she survives
and she gets rid of him and then she
launches this incredible rock and roll
career for another 40 years and this
worldwide sensation and and what I love
about it and it's a true story at the
end of the movie
uh it's it's just so great she's in this
divorce with Ike right and he's beating
the out of her beating the the crap
out of their kids he was horribly
abusive he was a drug addict all this
stuff and they're trying to decide what
they're going to do with the divorce and
she said to her lawyer
I don't want anything I mean there's
millions of dollars there's record
labels they own there's all this stuff
because I don't want anything
except my name meaning that he named her
Tina Turner Ike Turner named her Tina
Turner her name was Anna Mae Bullock and
she said I want to stay as Tina Turner
and that's all she got after the divorce
and then created this amazing thing like
I just love the story I just love it
Steve says might we get an update to a
question you have answered previously if
Governor DeSantis does run for president
in 2024 would you be helping him in the
campaign when he got elected would you
accept an invitation to be part of his
cabinet remember you are now a dad of
two which changes everything any idea of
what David would think of it well on the
on the dad front and all that I I love
Florida have I have I mentioned that on
the show before I think maybe I said it
once a couple weeks ago something nice
about Florida I I love love love our
life here we're building something so
great we this house that we live in
we've been doing a lot of work on and I
just love this place I love our
community here I love fighting for this
state and all those things so the idea
of being part of an Administration where
I'd be either living in DC or having to
go to DC every week and all that like
that honestly is not appealing to me
just on the personal front and being
away from the kids and and all that kind
of stuff so that's just like the
technical part on the back end on the
first part of it
um look I I think he is the best guy we
got
notwithstanding anything I just said the
good things that I said about Trump and
you know yesterday we uh we played you
know we did the State of the Union recap
and we played Trump state of the unions
at the end two clips and it's like man
that was a hell of a lot better than
what we got now but I but DeSantis to me
is the best guy that we got
and again do you send the best guy out
to the battlefield no and he doesn't he
maybe doesn't come back or he's
irreparably harmed or that battle cannot
be won meaning the federal battle like
that thing I don't know that's that's a
choice that they're gonna have to make
but let's just say it all happened let's
say he became president would I be I
would try to be involved in some way I
mean I think the way I'm involved now is
probably the best possible way like I'm
Not In Cahoots with the with the
campaign anyway I'm not paid by the
campaign in any way like I'm just waking
up they're doing the right thing and I
get to talk about it that that's pretty
beautiful so everyone kind of finds
their Lane within these things
but if they called me and they wanted
you know press secretary like I could
you think I could do what John Corinne
Jean-Pierre does I could do it I I feel
like I'd look pretty good in that red
dress with the uh with those shoulder
pads might be a bit much we'll see uh
kwanzi says I think you said you'd go to
the Gathering in London that Jordan
Peterson's heading up the wef opposition
group what kind of role do you see
yourself doing within that so if you're
not sure what he's referring to Jordan
is doing a conference it's a little
amorphous at the moment they're putting
the pieces together looks like it's
going to be October in London it is
going to be a massive conference that he
wants real people to attend not just the
elites real people can actually show up
and watch and be part of what's going on
they're going to do this in London
to counter the wef to do the bottom-up
version of what the the wef is doing
from the top down
um so what will my involvement be I'm
not sure yet I discussed it briefly with
Jordan obviously I could host panels
would probably be a very easy way of
doing things make some jokes jokes up
front kind of Welcome everybody there
maybe I'll do some interviews or
whatever it might be uh it's it's really
in the early stages of putting this
together but I will help Jordan in any
way that I possibly can if there's
something that I will be useful for I
will do it and uh and hopefully
hopefully I'll get to meet a bunch of
you guys there and and the people will
start making decisions for the people uh
Iliad says everything is infected with
this demonic political pathology I know
people who didn't know what gen I know
people who didn't know what gender
dysphoria existed now support the sexual
mutilation of children what will ever
wake them up oh I know people who didn't
know that uh it existed and now they
want emulate kids yeah it's wild
it's really wild like the the trans one
is the wildest because it's like if you
would have said to anyone 20 years ago
like we're going to have this Mass sort
of social contagion where a whole bunch
it's mostly young girls that want to
become young boys they're going to want
to take puberty blockers and chop their
breasts off and all of this stuff and
that parents are going to want to do it
in many cases parents would encourage it
schools would talk to these kids about
it privately call them other names use
these ridiculous pronouns all of the
cultural Machinery of a society would
push everyone in that direction
if you would have known that 20 years
ago you would have said you were nuts
and it is here and it is here and you're
you're very right people who did not
know this was a thing
two years ago are now cheering it on in
the name of decency intolerance and you
guys just wait you just you just wait
all of you parents who are doing this
who are doing this to feed some really
deep thing in you some endless black
hole in you you just wait till you're
till your kid your 13 year old daughter
who's now a 15 year old boy who's still
struggling with whatever he might be
struggling with uh you just wait till
he's 27 and uh has physical and mental
scars because of what you've done and
you you didn't act as the parent you
acted as an advocate for quote-unquote
science you just find out wait let's
push it past 27. now they're 67 and
you're 87 and they're about to put you
in the old age home they're not going to
put you in the nice one you know that
you're not going to Grand old people
Castle you're going to Shady Pines
Richard says When You observe the
positions that the far left Dems take on
society do you have flashbacks to your
time as a Democrat voter and the point
where you threw your hands up and tapped
out I do I think about it a lot because
I cannot believe
that although the Democrats were
certainly not as radical and crazed then
as they are now I cannot believe that
like a guy like Biden would have been
sensible to me 20 years ago like I I
wonder if if even if I went 10 years
back so I'm a lefty now and I'm still a
Democrat I think I would have been
looking at someone like AOC like this
doesn't make much sense and actually
much of my Awakening had to do with the
hysteria of these people I started
noticing the hysteria very early on uh
and AOC is a great example of the
hysteria so I don't know that I would
have ever been on board with her but but
the sort of just like middle of the road
kind of says the right thing but gets
everything wrong Democrat like Biden I
probably would have been in on that but
if you want to really know the answer to
that uh just this week we put up a
compilation video of my four prageru
videos with a little bit of uh of new
content in between my commentary on what
was going on in the world over these
past six years and you can find out sort
of what I was thinking then versus what
I was thinking now and Chris let's put
the link to that in the description I'm
talking to my guy Chris through the
computer machine right now can you do
that for me Chris in the description
let's put that preview link uh Miss mama
panda says any plans to go to to go
watch a SpaceX launch I can see them
from my house however I want to see it
up close Justin or Luke may want to be
an astronaut that listen I got the Elon
connection right now maybe I can get one
of these kids to be an astronaut I would
go to Mars I really would I think maybe
I do the show a couple more years and
then you know hopefully SpaceX has
continued and elon's like all right we
can take x amount of people I mean I
would want to take the family but like
right that's going to be the problem
they're going to want to take a lot of
single people and and couples maybe
without kids with a bunch of fertilized
embryos that they're going to plant
there then an alien is going to infect
one of them and then take over the ship
you've seen the movie
um but I would do that sort of thing
anyway I don't think I can go where is
it where'd we say it was again it's in
yeah it's near Orlando on the coast over
there obviously it's a couple hours up
and I think I'm away that weekend but
you know they'll keep doing more of
these things
um Rich says who are the top three Front
Runners to be the next governor of
Florida well it's interesting because
there is a chance that the scientist
does not finish the term and makes the
move on the presidential thing but
either way uh there will be another
election at some point uh I think that I
think the three big ones right now are
Jimmy Patronus who I don't think you
guys have
hurt many of you have not heard of
certainly if you don't live in Florida
but he's the CFO the Chief Financial
Officer of Florida I think he's got a
really bright future in front of him I
like him he's had a lot to do with the
reconstruction after Hurricane Ian uh
strikes me as a decent guy and I think
he could be good he seems kind of
Television ready and and he's a fighter
speaking of a fighter I think Byron
Donalds who you definitely know now if
you've been watching the show I've
interviewed him a few times congressman
from South West Florida really good dude
and and I basically asked him and he
said there's probably only one job for
me after this and that's governor of
Florida he didn't quite say governor of
Florida but it was implied uh maybe
Francis Suarez who's now the mayor of
Miami uh who I think would obviously
make a great Governor he may have
presidential Ambitions on his own uh
there's a couple options there Jeanette
Nunez who is our uh lieutenant governor
uh I think she could be quite good so
Florida the thing with Florida is and
one of the reasons I'm somewhat willing
to to back the DeSantis for president
thing if it's going to happen is I feel
like Florida is going to be okay the
people really have learned the right
lessons here are our politics makes
sense our systems here are working I
don't think DeSantis would just be like
all right I'm going to be the president
I'm out of here he loves this freaking
State I think he would make sure that it
would make sense whoever would follow
him and what policies would come after
that and the rest of it so
but we'll see we'll see if it comes to
fruition uh Geller says one of the
reasons that news channels are corrupt
is that they're not pay for use so the
user gets the service for free
advertisers pay the costs and the
channel isn't beholden to the user to be
truthful locals addresses this by making
the channel accountable to the users but
are there other areas that are or should
be going pay for use you know the pay
for use thing is interesting look my
feeling with locals was that first off
I'm independent
and what I wanted to make sure was I am
not reliant on YouTube or anything else
for all my rev because on any given
moment they could not only close my
channel they can demonetize us they can
cut our ads they can depress Us in the
algorithm there was no way to run a
functional business like that so by me
creating locals and shout out to those
of you that are joining us right now I'm
reading your questions at
reubenreport.locals.com uh Stephanie you
want to take a picture of me and take a
backstage picture of me right now and
post it in the locals chat just for the
locals people could you do that for me
my feeling was that if we if the only
way we could truly go independent was if
I was only beholden to my audience what
was interesting about that is you also
don't want to be captured by your
audience meaning you don't want to know
that your audience only thinks this one
thing and thus you must cater to that
one thing all the time I've really
really tried not to do that when I've
when I've been out on the road book tour
and whatever and I meet you guys and
people will always say people say this
to be probably more than anything else
well they say two things they go Dave
you you help keep me sane that's
probably the number one I get and number
two is Dave I don't agree with
everything you say but I still love you
something like that and it's like great
that's freaking fantastic and that also
helps me not get captured for example I
I'm I'm really okay with the 15-week
abortion thing I have a feeling most of
my audience is not so most of my
audience in that case is more
conservative than I am let's say and
there might be some other issues like
that I think what you guys respect about
me is the is the that you see that I'm
doing my best to tell you something true
amidst the madness and the fact that
people want to throw in a few dollars to
keep that going so we can keep growing
and doing everything that we're doing
and and you know pay everybody nicely
and all of that is is absolutely
wonderful but to your point on
advertisers and how the the news
channels then are not beholden to the
user it's interesting because so CNN
think about it CNN CNN needs views they
need clicks so they they have to get
people interested in certain things when
were CNN's ratings the highest they ever
were it was during Trump and this is the
perverse nature of the business
in a weird way the system wants Trump to
come back because they will get views
and they will get clicks and then they
will lie about all the things related to
Trump and he'll give them plenty of
fodder for that as well but that is a
match made in hell
and actually I think that does explain a
lot of the dissent that we've been on
if there was just a guy who came in and
it's interesting because this is sort of
the scientist but DeSantis is also a
fighter and they're trying to make him
into Trump but if there was a guy who
just came in and he was just like you
know here are my policies I believe in
America I want to kind of get out of
your way we don't want any of this woke
crazy stuff I believe in reality that's
my stuff you know and I'm going to go
about and do my business the media would
not know what to do with that guy and I
think that there's a DeSantis version of
that they wouldn't know what to do with
him because it's like wait a minute
that's sanity and decency and not
keeping everyone you know tapped in and
drugged by the system that's not good
for the bottom line and I would never
want to be uh someone that was feeding
that monster I really try not to I
really try not to but yeah the The
Selective pressures on Advertising
versus subscription and everything else
it can make it quite uh difficult you
know we're going to do a post game show
speaking of locals we're doing a post
game show in just a moment if you have
not had enough of me there's more to
come
reubenreport.locals.com if you haven't
subscribed on Rumble please go ahead and
do that rumble.com Ruben report part two
of my interview with Dr Robert Malone
it's quite chilling I mean some of what
he says about what he thinks he thinks
we have not seen the worst when it comes
to the vaccine injuries yet as a matter
of fact I think I said to him I said
have we seen the worst he said it's not
that I fear it I know it I mean pretty
freaking chilling uh all right we're
gonna leave you with a cold close Little
Joe Biden a little Jill Biden for you at
Ruben report.locals.com in just a second
you have a good rest of the night did
they bring alcohol in here
we'll do better next time
[Music]
foreign